am montagabend landet die erste
österreichische leichtathletik medaille
der männer seit es um typische spiele
gibt in wien schwechat
es ist eine bronzemedaille und er hat
sie sich verdient umgehängt diskuswerfer
lukas weißhaidinger
[Musik]
sowohl als einmal sicher angebracht habe
aber doch sehr langen flug und ja dass
die erste leichtathletik modelle format
in österreich ist der bayer dem her bis
schwer diese schweren teile aber fühlt
sich jetzt auch emile richterrecht
leichter
[Musik]
man muss im moment wenn man bescheiden
sagt dass man überhaupt in der lage ist
mit einer mitteilung des offizieller
wenigsten und sand sowie sportler die wo
es ist das größte genauso vielen jahr
mit einer mitteilung
das macht mir wirklich sehr
nachdenklicher welt muss man da wirklich
zu haben
[Musik]
ohne bundesheer das ist die schlacht
verloren heißt es ist
das obwohl er gar nichts was darauf
steht
ausstehen kann dann muss entstehen ich
denke mal ordentlich trainieren kann man
nicht umfällt dringend springen schaffen
und dann kamen wir dann einmal dadurch
zu den endlichen spiele fahren um
medaillen mitkämpfen
[Musik]
ja es wird gehen wir auf stur gestorben
teilt er sich mit frau wirklich
besonderen leider haben an der feier
unterschritten
der liegt der fokus war in den letzten
monaten vor gericht
fühlt
russland
familien
fürsten
ja privat fern
[Musik]